c'est donc en mai dernier morissette a
fait le vaccin oui première dose oui
alors uclat elles étaient méfiants ils
voulaient faire absolument non vous
savez nous on est une génération au
vaccin donc on a été comme tout le monde
un petit peu conditionné on a commencé à
nous faire peur et puis quand on a eu la
nouvelle d'un vaccin un truc c'était une
bonne nouvelle on y est allés à assurer
science alors on a en a en un peu on est
un peu particulier ce qu'on a un cabaret
et donc forcément avoir continué
d'accueillir nos clients il y avait
quand même aussi en partie de
l'obligation de se vacciner c'est à dire
que moi morissette par exemple s'est
jamais vaccinées contre la grippe à la
kalach mauricette à la 72 ans mais elle
est belle ma femme un temps incertain
pour certains s'appelle bénéfice risque
alors avant tout je voudrais remettre de
l'humain dans tout ça si vous me
permettez et je voudrais vous dire que
par exemple pour ses amis ses mots mort
et c'est tout simplement pour ses
enfants basse et maman et puis pour ses
petits enfants c'est manu il ya plein de
gens qui vont se reconnaître à travers
ça est ce que je voudrais dire
aujourd'hui si c'est surtout
vous auriez tort d'imaginer que ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres voilà et je
voudrais qu au plus profond de votre
coeur je dis ça aux gens qui sont devant
leur téléviseur et même ici sur le
plateau vous pensez à la personne que
vous aimez le plus au monde et à la
place de ces deux mots horribles qui
sont bénéfice risque vous mettez la
personne que vous avez de plus ou moins
de vous la mettez à la place de maurice
est alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour
moi c'est raconter ce qui s'est passé
c'est que elle a eu la deuxième
vaccination et que une quinzaine de
jours après alors que avant il y avait
aucun symptôme
le médecin tout allait bien pour moi et
ça allait bien je veux dire allait elle
savait aller sur scène elle apprenait
ses textes elle faisait ses chansons il
ya eu aucun signe avant coureur ce qui
va se passer un quinze jours après
quinze jours après elle a commencé à
avoir des fourmillements sur la jambe
gauche
quelques vertiges et puis da ça a été
une escalade de symptômes assez
rapidement on est allé voir un médecin
il a pensé que les vertiges c'était dû à
l'oreille interne
elle avait une légère douleur dans la
dans la cuisse gauche sont qu'il a il
s'est dit que c'était peut-être un
problème de sciatique dons qui lui a
donné des anti-inflammatoires et un
médicament qui s'appelle temps gagné
pour les vertiges tout en nous disant
écoutez c'est bizarre on va quand même
faire une recherche
éventuellement pour les vertiges donc il
a prescrit un irm
très vite moi j'ai voulu aller faire
cette irm parce qu'on était juste un
petit peu avant les vacances et comme
vous le savez c'est compliqué d'avoir
des rendez vous c'est très compliqué
action donc on a eu un rendez vous on a
filé irm et la
d116 qui est tombé rapidement nous a dit
légères traces d'un ancien a baissé
alors qu'elle avait aucun malaise pas de
bouche tordue comme on peut trouver dans
un avc traditionnelle et puis derrière
ça s'est enchaîné elle a commencé à
avoir des tremblements sur la jambe
gauche qui partait d'un seul coup tout
seul le bras gauche
et là on s'est posé des questions et on
a vu un premier neurologue qui nous a
dit écoutez moi je suis pas d'accord
avec l'analyse du radiologue c'est pas
un problème vasculaire ce que je vois
sur l'irm c'est un problème
inflammatoires et là moi dans ma tête je
le rappelle j'étais devant cette femme
neurologue jeudi inflammatoires ça a
fait tilt parce que forcément dans le
cosi dans tout ce qu'on entend il est
souvent question de problèmes
inflammatoires donc de là je lui ai dit
écoutez elle a été vaccinée à 15 jours
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il peut y
avoir un lien et elle n'a posé des
questions quels vaccins ou jim keyzer
quand voilà et là elle a rédigé un
courrier est las d'écouter il faut faire
un autre irm
avec une injection parce que j'ai besoin
de devoir plus précisément ce qui s'est
passé et sur le courrier à l'indiquer
justement que il y avait eu une
injection et c'est donc elle m'a pas dit
tout de suite non c'est pas possible
c'est pas de vaccin voilà j'ai trouvé
qu'elle était assez assez étonné de ce
que je lui apportais
on a fait le deuxième irm à l'hôpital
foch à l'injection donc un c'est tout
avec injection et là je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie parce qu'elle commençait à
voir ce qu'on appelle des cloning dans
le bras gauche donc il n'ya vraiment
mauvais dans un tube donc moi j'ai dit
aux médecins écoutez si elle a le bras
qui part tout seul voilà donc ils m'ont
autorisé exceptionnellement est à ses
côtés avec un bouton au cas où justement
il se passe quelque chose pour l'arrêter
et d'un seul coup derrière là j'ai vu
derrière d'un espèce d'aquarium là ça
s'est affolé quand ils ont commencé à
faire les rênes et quelqu'un à venir
téléphoné j'ai senti qu'ils avaient
quelque chose de bizarre et en partant
l'infirmière qui nous avait accueillis
elle m'a souhaité bon courage et là je
vais si mais c'est quand même étonnant
on va faire un irm et pourquoi le qui
vous parle de rien et vous disent parle
de rien puisque en plus on est dans une
société où tout et vous donne les
résultats et vous disent
non y'a rien et c'est tout c'est
banaliser on vous donne un code pour que
le lendemain vous y voir vous même sur
internet éventuellement ce que vous
pouvez avoir vous allez voir votre
médecin a préféré vote neurologue après
avec les résultats non parce que pour au
pareil le neurologue entre temps il est
pas disponible il répondu à mes appels
enfin c'est au clan vous dit rien vous
partez on vous dit rien on ne dit rien
et le lendemain je me connecte et là je
vois pas dans la conclusion de l'irm est
dans la dent dans les comptes-rendus
suspicion de segi machin tu sais quoi ça
y est j'y joue donc fait une recherche
sur internet et là je tombe sur kruissel
jacob mars et la maladie de la vache
folle c'est la maladie de la vache
hominem en voilà et là je me rappellerai
toute ma vie parce que forcément mort et
cet été là à ce moment là le parlaient
encore un elle parle elle marchait
encore avec difficulté et elle voit bien
qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passait je
me dis mais qu'est ce qu'ils achètent
une cache quelque chose
et j'avoue que j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de
craquer parce que maladie de la vache
folle c'est vous pouvez même pas vous
battre quoi vous savez quand il ya plein
de gens aujourd'hui qui sont dans la
situation avec des gens malades chez eux
mais ils ont il ya une issue il ya un
espoir même si vous avez un cancer vous
dites voilà ce qu'on va se battre et là
j'ai ma femme en face de moi et vous
font moi même je sais je l'aï va mourir
qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce que
julie bon voilà c'est un truc de fou et
vous savez cyril
cette aventure en fait j'essaie toujours
moi d'en retirer le positif ça m'a
permis de rencontrer et rencontrer des
gens et tout à l'heure les médecins
disaient qu'ils allaient les témoignages
sur les réseaux sociaux il faut
peut-être entre guillemets pas les
prendre trop au sérieux je voulais vous
dire ou à monsieur quand j'ai été
médiatisée la première fois en direct
j'ai donné mon numéro de téléphone
justement pour pouvoir répondre à des
gens comme vous qui finalement quelque
part banalise un petit peu je ne prenais
ça pas mal mais ce film peut-être de
votre formation de médecins alors que
moi je pense que la médecine est aussi
de l'observation mais d'observation de
tous les jours moi je vis avec russell
et jacob depuis cinq mois variez vos
pieds de ma femme et j'ai appris plein
de choses sur la maladie et je pense que
donc il faut il faut observer hélas ce
jour-là à l'émission pour justement
pallier à ce genre de remarque je donne
mon numéro de téléphone en direct en
disant écoutez moi j'espère me tromper
j'espère que ma femme elle est
finalement c'est un cas isolé
j'aurais préféré et donc je donne mon
nouveau team ford en direct ce soir
syrie devait refaire la même chose parce
que vous verrez dans quelques semaines
je pourrai vous faire profiter de tous
ces témoignages donc j'invite les gens
derrière leur poste de télévision parce
que ça c'est important
des témoignages de la vraie vie alors
dedans il faut trier et croyez moi vous
savez je suis si bien honnête pour faire
le tri je me suis entouré de médecins
j'ai une neurologue à la retraite qui me
suit cas étudiés dix cas c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai collecté grâce à mon
premier témoignage 22 cas de maladie de
la vache folle sous sont survenus
quinze jours après la deuxième injection
tous sont survenus après le même vaccin
se dire je vais le nommer tout la sonde
céphise heures
c'est une maladie extrêmement rare
c'est à dire qu'on est un cas sur un
million
je vous dis pas avec certitude que ça
vient de ça mais vous non plus vous
pourrez pas me dire parce que sinon vous
mentir aux gens c'est dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce que droit dans les
yeux vous pouvez dire aux gens je vous
garantis messieurs dames que ce vaccin
ne pourra pas voulu déclencher des
maladies que vous avez en vous dont la
maladie de la vache folle parce que
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit que ça ira
d'ivoire et 7 elle l'avait elle ya même
un euro qui m'a dit oui écouter
effectivement à l'hôpital américain un
très sérieux qui m'a dit effectivement
ça peut venir du vaccin mais vous savez
on verra si une explosion des cas
vingt-deux cas tous ceux revenus dans
les mêmes conditions forme ultra rapide
donc on pense qu'on est surtout sur une
nouvelle forme de la maladie de la vache
folle
ça mérite un questionnement ça mérite
quand même des pouvoirs publics de se
poser des questions vous savez
aujourd'hui mes enfants mes petits
enfants on a obtenu la semaine dernière
en moins d'une semaine de la sécurité
sociale une dispense de vaccination
parce que si c'est génétique j'ai pas
envie que mon fils vacciner il développe
la même maladie que sa mère ou que ses
petits enfants
donc c'est bien qu'on reconnaît quand
même qu'il peut y avoir un lien je vais
pas vous dire que tout ce cauchemar je
déconne témoignage je vous assure que je
peux vous les montre et je les ai ya des
numéros de téléphone ya des gens
derrière cette ce pad c'est pas des
fêtes nous tous à 90% ont les mêmes
symptômes sont morissette avait au début
des vertiges des bruches des flottements
dans les alpes hier mg on a des gens qui
ont des faits des avc sans faire de
malaise alors attention je suis pas en
train de vous dire que tout le monde va
attraper la malle et de la sole mais le
seul point commun dans tous ces gens
c'est qu'ils ont été tous vaccinés maman
je suis pas anti vaccins march est vrai
qu on écoute la réponse du professeur
espèce que c'est un second disque est ce
que vous vous dites là dessus professeur
n'était ce qu'un pur c'est que ses
collègues et lui dit elle avait en elle
et la développer non je vous répondrais
est ce que vous avez dit en introduction
m'a beaucoup frappé et je suis
complètement en phase avec vous quand
vous dites qu'il faut rajouter de
l'humain et je vois en face de moi je
vois un homme qu'il souffre qui a la
douleur et ça je respecte complètement g
vous dire j'ai un peu l'habitude je vois
des gens qui souffrent face de moi et
votre démarche
votre souffrance je la respecte je
respecte comme soignants puisque je sais
mon métier et je comprends complètement
votre démarche le concept jacob c'est
une maladie vous l'avez dit extrêmement
rare et une centaine de cas en france
extrêmement mystérieuse
encore aujourd'hui on est on ne connaît
pas encore bien le mécanisme
complètement si vous voulez en dehors de
tout ce qu'on connaissait comme maladies
infectieuses puisque on connaît les
virus on connaît bactéries aucun des
parasites et là c'est une protéine qui
va qui va être l'agent infectieux et
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau et connaît encore du mal
aujourd'hui à élucider
donc je comprends complètement et mes
premières pensées enfin vont plutôt vers
une pauvre femme j'espère qu'elle est
bien prise en charge qu'elle est
entourée d'une équipe de soignants qui
sont bienveillants qu'elle est entre de
bonnes mains après
si vous voulez je veux pas rajouter de
la souffrance à la souffrance peut-être
qu'il y ait un lien je ne vais pas vous
dire que vous êtes dans l'erreur d'abord
vous dire ça ça serait malhonnête de ma
part mais en plus ça pourrait vous faire
du mal donc je vais pas le faire
vous collectez des cas de creutzfeldt
jakob chez des gens qui ont jusqu'à dix
marques
collectives degré ayant un accent et
vous dites qu'elle à 100 par an en
attendant c'est ce que disent les les
publications scientifiques non c'est ce
que disent les publications
scientifiques je vais finir si vous avez
je décolle collecter 20 20 cas de
conseil d'accor qui sont survenus quinze
jours après la vaccination à tous ses
sauts ce que je vous invite à faire
c'est absolument de les signaler à la
pharmacovigilance non c'est le métier et
ils n'ont pas du tout ils ont aucun
intérêt si vous voulez à à promouvoir le
vaccin leur métier c'est exactement ce
que vous faites avec des méthodes on va
dire éprouvé de faire si vous voulez un
lien entre le vaccin et cette maladie
donc vous êtes un lanceur d alerte mais
adressez vous si vous voulez aux bonnes
personnes que sont les médecins de la
pharmacovigilance pour qu'il fasse ce
travail
et je ne vais pas vous dire non vous
avez top stark comme quand je vois tous
les effets indésirables qu'ils sont qui
sont dans les réseaux sociaux jeux les
minimise pas pas du tout comme ça a été
dit c'est des effets indésirables il
faut
entraîner une démarche scientifique que
je vous ai résumé la pharmacovigilance
d'oncle enquête approfondie
la comparaison avec une population non
vaccinée pour se faire une idée si vous
voulez un scientifique du fait qu'ils
aient un lien entre le médicament et la
survenue de cette maladie